my experience of the banking crisis has
affected my country and the steps that
we took and the lessons that we learnt
I'd like to thank you for the
opportunity to speak to you and I do
hope that in the next 20 minutes or so I
should be through and then take
questions so that we can address any
particular areas of interest that you
may have there are few early slides
which basically cover ground that's well
known I don't need to go into what
happen with the global financial crisis
and what went wrong starting from the
subprime mortgage crisis poor regulation
lacks supervision the huge
concentrations the contagion
what up the stock market and commodity
prices now for us in Nigeria we didn't
have any first round effects because our
banks were not linked in any way to the
international markets directly but we
did suffer from second round effects the
price of all crashing as you know at one
stage before the crisis all prices have
gone up to 147 dollars a barrel at a
point during the crisis all prices went
to below $40 a barrel now all is only 12
13 % of Nigeria's GDP but it plays a
very disproportionate role as far as
financial stability is concerned it's
about 98 percent of export earnings
because of the lack of diversification
lack of focus and cultural exports it
accounts for about 80 percent directly
or indirectly of government revenues and
because of the rate at which government
spending is a major part of when you
supply it drives the stock market so
what happens is you've got very high
correlation like all other oil producing
countries which in asset prices and the
price of commodities when oil price goes
up reserves go up you get an inflow
because of strong currencies stock
markets go up when all price crashes
stock markets crash
so between 2004 to 2008 with banking
system consolidation and banks having
much bigger balance sheets we had banks
that had huge exposures to the capital
market and also huge exposures to all
marketing unfortunately Nigeria country
that's an all producing country yet our
biggest import from the UK is petroleum
products so you had banks that had huge
exposures to all marketers and to the
capital market and the crashing oil
price followed by a crash in the stock
market meant that the balance sheets
were worked out now basically the crisis
in Nigeria was a result of eight related
factors there was a macroeconomic
instability caused by a large uncertain
capital inflows with high oil prices
there were major major failures in
corporate governance in banks which
we'll talk about a lack of investment
consumer sophistication inadequate
disclosure and transparency about
financial portion of banks up to the eve
of the crisis every bank claimed not to
have what they call toxic assets which
became a word that were literally just
true they did have any toxic assets and
it have been subprime loans where they
had bad loans but they didn't have toxic
assets and nobody ever asked well a
curator of toxic but you have
non-performing loans you know so those
that are critical gaps in regulation and
the framework the whole idea of
universal banking and not looking very
closely at what subsidy resurging with
money and even supervision enforcement's
internal weaknesses in the central bank
and certain weaknesses in the business
environment now in 2009 when I became
governor we had this situation where a
significant number of banks were on the
verge of collapse and we sent in
examiner's and we discovered that eight
major banks at the country very grave
situation and these eight banks
accounted for 30% of total deposit
liabilities 40% of total assets so
clearly if they've gone under the entire
system would have gone and the first
thing we had to do was obviously
take a decision do we disclose to the
market the full extent of this crisis
and risk
everybody run away from the banks or do
we continue with the old policy of
pretending that the system was fine and
safe we took the decision that if we
didn't disclose the band's would
collapse anyway and therefore it was
better to come out clean and say this is
the extent of the problem and also say
while waiting to to fix it and it was a
difficult decision which is why I can
understand the Europeans even though I
do this I don't think they're right why
can they stand the difficulty they are
having with basically coming out to say
this how bad the situation is so every
day we come up with one new problem
after the other and and there's a sense
that there's a much much bigger problem
that's not being disclosed and it's what
happened in Japan for for several
decades so having looked at Japan having
looked at the experiences of say
Malaysia how they responded compared to
how Japan responded we said that I would
go the Malaysian way we basically looked
at the bank's assess the damage and came
out and said listen you've got these
eight bands and they're in a bad
situation now obviously for us we we're
not going to see that the bankers in
position and then just put in capital we
removed the entire management of those
banks and put in new management and then
injected money in what we call the
keeping banks on life support before we
took them to a safe harbor now the
replacement of the CEOs and executive
management clearly opened the door to
seeing things that had not been seen by
the regulator before among what we saw
for example was that a significant part
of the loans that were Austin stably
given to third parties we're actually
given to s PVS owned by the CEOs some of
those loans we're literally just shipped
out of the country
we had a CEO that we put in jail and we
recovered two
pieces of real estate in Dubai plus some
property in Johannesburg plus some
property on the Potomac you know in
addition to what was she had a measure
over she had in Nigeria and this is
maybe the richest woman in the country
one of the richest women in Africa and
basically targeted as a leader of
business so we did have these situations
we took some difficult decisions for
example we asked every CEO that had
spent ten years as CEO to leave
irrespective of whether the bank had
problems or not to na de Melo who are
CEO of UBA UBA didn't have a problem but
he'd been there for over 10 years and we
asked him to go
as same thing with a gym oviya we also
asked non-executive directors who spent
12 years to another reason we did this
was we discovered very strong
correlation between CEO stain for a very
very long time and very weak governance
many of the people in top management had
joined the bank as very junior officers
and they usually had this high level of
turnover the levels just below the CEOs
in one case we had an executive director
who used to be a special assistant to
the MD and he had risen to be an IDI so
when the MDC is jumping says how high
you know and so we felt 10 years it was
enough and therefore in Nigeria today
you can't serve as a CEO of a bank for
more than 10 years it's stretch for the
non-executive directors the same
situation after 12 years they begin to
get very comfortable they borrow from
the banks at sometimes not as another
arm's length concessionary terms on
collateral concessionary terms on
interest rates they get to do some
consultancy work for the bank they get
compromised and they lose their
independence so after 12 years they
leave the board now so the first lesson
I think for us was that pretending that
something is a problem does not make it
go away
and maybe one day Europe will stop
pretending and basically just say this
is a problem the problem is that to fix
the banks in Italy and Spain will cost
about two-thirds of the total tax
revenues of the government of the
Republic of Germany now it's a bad
problem but somebody has to find the
money somewhere so it's actually better
to think of where the money will come
from and as you'll see what we did was
to fix the banks and then make the banks
pay so we have a wherever long-term bond
taken by Hong Kong and for the next 10
to 12 years every bank in Nigeria
contributes the sinking fund so the
banks are going to pay the cost of the
cleanup you know so that's it
okay second lesson is that central banks
actually emerging markets need to have a
role beyond traditional ascribe to them
and I think this goes beyond emerging
markets we've seen that even in the
developed world the UK today has what is
called a funding for lending program
which basically is about the central
bank giving low-interest funding to
bands so that they can lend it to SMEs
you know so that's beyond traditional
monetary policy and this is one of the
things we had to look at because at the
heart of the crisis in Europe and
America and in Nigeria is the fact that
banks have moved away from their core
function of intermediation savings into
the real economy and the question
remains how do you make sure after
fixing the banks that they don't go back
to lend into the capital market let me
just lend into the real estate market
how do you get them to lend to
agriculture you've got 42% of Nigerian
GDP being agriculture before the crisis
banks were lending less than 1% of their
portfolio to a Greek and therefore the
whole idea of the central bank working
with means of Agriculture have a proper
value chain transformation program so
that our culture becomes profitable and
commercially viable so that banks can
lend agriculture becomes important it so
longer possible to just sit down and
tell banks to lend to agriculture and
preach to them or criticize them for not
the real risk issues have to be
addressed if you have a rice production
at 2 metric tonnes per hectare when in
Eastern Africa is six and in Asia it's
anything from 10 to 14 you're never
going to produce rice sell compete with
imported rice from Thailand or imported
rice from China so you've got to address
real productivity issues before rice
becomes commercially viable and
competitive if you if you're producing
cassava and you don't have production of
starch or finished or ethanol near the
farms what happens is you transport huge
amounts of cassava occur for hours and
you just transporting water and and the
business model is not viable so Nigeria
today is the world's largest producer of
cassava nobody knows that because we
don't produce any ethanol we don't
produce any starch we're not in the
value-added segments and now we now have
investments coming in near in the air
the cassava farms to produce such an
ethanol I don't know how many of you
know that Nigeria is the world's largest
importer of tomato paste it's a
population of 167 million people we
produce tomato but 50% of it gets lost
between the farm under market there is
no investment in storage there are no
processing plants near the farms so we
import tomato paste from China now what
we do not import from China we import
from Italy from a company owned by the
Chinese so it's a big problem I mean why
should you import tomato paste Nigeria
is an exporter of crude oil and we
import it so their major structural
problems always say we come from a
country that specialises in exporting
what it does not have and importing what
it has so we import petroleum products
we import food ok and we or what do we
export to export electricity Tunisia
because they have if we don't they'll
build a dam on the Niger so we don't
have enough in Nigeria but we have to
export to the
we even had a military government that
exported democracy you know true the
elections in Liberia were conducted by
the Nigerian military administration of
a budget so that's how good we are and
so the real challenge is how do you
start exporting what you have and stop
importing or what you have so we didn't
just have to bail out banks we had to
reorganize the banker's committee and
say how do we build on the ashes of this
crisis a new banking system that
actually intermediates into the real
economy and we had interventions in the
power sector we try to keep the airlines
afloat and we had what was a president
of this funding for lending we learned
we lent banks money at one percent on
the condition that they would refinance
there those SMEs for about 10 to 15
years at no more than 7 percent and it
worked and I think we do have some
numbers at the end of this presentation
on the number of jobs we created and the
factories we kept afloat now there are
implications obviously for central bank
independence we get into this because we
get into an area we've got to criticize
government policy where you have to make
public comments about the fiscal
position where you have to talk about
agricultural policy and then government
feels it has the right to begin to
encroach on your independence so in a
sense when I write my memoirs I think
one of the negatives of the last four
years is that the autonomy of the
central bank has on several occasions
been under threat and we've had to fight
tooth and nail to stop amendments to the
act okay but and sometimes government
can claim deliberate provocation from
the central bank second is that we need
to be a source of innovative solutions
and as an incorporation of Niger is a
good example what we did here was to
look at the Malaysian response to the
financial crisis and there are three
institutions in Malaysia that we rolled
into one
I'm corn one is the diner hotter that's
a dynamo doll and there's a corporate
debt restructuring desk one basically is
a standard Resolution Trust Company that
purchases non-performing loans the other
is an institution that recapitalize --is
distressed banks and the third
restructures debt now what we did was to
set up one institution in Nigeria that
does all three so first step was to put
in liquidity support into the banks I
remove the management and then promise
to recapitalize the banks bring the
capital to zero and purchase
non-performing loans on the condition
that the banks agreed to a merger so
five of the banks were able to agree to
merger terms with with other
institutions or accept foreign investors
as at the case of Union Bank and what we
then did was unconscious the number form
in loans and the gap below zero was
filled by an pawn and then the new bank
chopped up and and that way were able to
recapitalize the banks and uncon did
this by issuing bonds that were
guaranteed by the federal government so
we didn't actually print money so you'd
have like twelve fifteen year bonds that
will be issued guaranteed by the federal
government we should guidelines that
another central bank to invest in those
instruments so there's less government
bonds
and the banks would take that and then
when it comes to repayment of the bonds
we don't from this sinking fund which we
can't be tied to by the banks so with
that you are able to bring down
non-performing loans across the industry
of about 30% to under 5% I think about 2
or 3% so we've got strong liquidity
Nigerian banks have karaokes ratio of
about 17 18 percent now basically are
the most capitalized banks on the
continent maybe on the globe at the
moment and that's what I'm Kahn has been
able to do so the key thing with amp con
is that it was able to do all of this
fix the banks with yes engine accept
with IMF are they fine with what has
been done but most important we did this
at minimal cost to the taxpayer and well
it depends me complain that we're not
all responsible for what happened our
justification is that if those banks
have gone under everybody would have
gone under and therefore a bailout and I
think this is true of all of Nigerian
true of the rest of the world I mean if
if RBS had not been bailed out if if
America had not build out Citibank and
above all these banks and everybody else
would have gone under so in a sense and
bailout for two or three bands it's a
bit of an entire industry and therefore
the industry should pay for it that's
the moral of it and the fourth lesson is
universal banking I think this was
something we all fell in love with and
I'm typical of emerging markets and an
Africa when when something catches the
fashion in Europe and America it becomes
fashionable everywhere so universal
banking became a fashionable thing and
everybody adopted it but what does it do
basically what it does is it allows
institutions to take basically cheap
funds from depositors when looking for
very high returns because they put even
their money looking for safety and then
arbitrage those by taking them to highly
higher returns speculative areas under
one roof and then there is no
transparency so usually when you go with
your money to a bank you're not looking
for very high return you just want to
make sure that whenever you want your
money it's there
but the bank is then supposed to keep
that money safely and not take risks if
you want to take the risk you go and put
you give a stock broker and trading
equities or you going to give a real
estate dealer and trading real estate
you don't go to a bank if you can't take
that risk
but these funds that were placed there
for safety we're basically invested in
high-risk areas
gambling asset prices using subsidiaries
so we broke up the universal banking
model
and we didn't just break it up we said
you can have holding companies so and
it's interesting when we gave the bank's
the option of setting up cold calls and
set up guidelines that would make
transparent movement of funds from the
band's subsidiaries out of the 21 banks
in Nigeria only three opted to remain in
on van non banking business we tells you
that the business was never really
profitable on its own it was only
profitable if it could leverage the
deposit base of the commercial banks
very few banks do have strong investment
banking skills very few banks were
really into proper investment very few
bands have the ability to get investors
putting money in a PE fund or a venture
capital fund so it was always depositors
money going into into those businesses
and the three that remained two of them
had started off as investment banks
anyway so FCM be used to be faceting
merchant bank so it already had a strong
investment banking franchise Stanwyck
had I BTC which was already a strong
investment bank the only other Bank that
never really had a strong investment
banking franchise was First Bank which
has remained a whole Co so I suppose
they've got to build those capabilities
but every other Bank opted to exit non
core banking business since the
opportunities for making that kind of
money no longer there now we had rules
around the ring fence we electrified it
so so if if first Bank for example where
to place money with FB and capital which
is owned by the same hold code if that
money is not secured it's not
collateralized as a loan we'll take it
straight out of first bank's capital so
we would assume that the money was being
placed for the purpose of speculation
and it should not be depositors funds so
we take so that makes it extremely
difficult and expensive to move money
from whatever and the same thing with
moving money to hold Co
that of capital so you can't go through
your whole code and go around because
ridiculous capital repatriation those
are guidelines that obviously people
have screamed about but they're the kind
of guidelines that address the actual
problem because what can be done under
one roof can be done under two roofs so
you've got to make sure that it's not
done and if it's done it's done with
capital Norwood depositors funds by
ring-fencing depositors money so the
whole discussion on the Volcker Rule and
universal banking we've gone ahead less
than five kozma protection one of the
things that shocked me in the central
bank was a central bank did not have a
cosmo Protection Department at all we
had to set it up so a lot of the
complaints that could have come from
people whose money was taken to buy
shares and that could have raised an
alarm when in advance
we're not seen so working on that and
getting banks to set up Qasimi help
desks reviewing the guide bank charges
and so on number six coordination among
regulatory bodies the banks are quoted
entities and the shares are traded on
the stock exchange regulated by SEC so
and a lot of what happened in the bank
industry happen through the stock market
just like here so a lack of coordination
between SEC and the central bank was a
problem the the whole idea of margin
lending stockbrokers just taken money
from the banks manipulating share prices
for banks buying shares for bank chief
executives that they knew were not
transparent all of that happened because
of a lack of coordination between the
banking system regulator and the capital
markets regulator so what we've done is
to strengthen the financial sector which
the regulatory considered committee
which has
a banker's chair also has SEC Nikon the
insurance regulator pen calm the
Pensions Regulator we have the stock
exchange DG as an observer we have the
capital Corporate Affairs Commission
also as an observer and basically that
is a forum where we now begin to share
information and what we found is that
those banks that had the major problems
we're also banks that had issues with
SEC and we're not - we're aware of that
which is typical if you have a problem
of one regulator usually have one with
other regulators but if you don't
compare notes you don't get a full
picture of how how bad the governance
issues are with these institutions
secondly for cross-border supervision
we've set up our second college of
supervisors where you have directors of
anticipation of all banks also intro
banks in West Africa meeting and it's
not been upgraded to the African college
of supervisors so there's something that
we relate as Nigeria and it's becoming
extremely useful because these colleges
now meet twice a year at the Continental
level four times a year at the regional
level and they talk about problems
within their country we actually conduct
joint supervision now certainly with the
Nigerian banks the have subsidiaries in
African countries we go there and
conduct joint exercises with the central
banks in those countries and share
information in a manner that was not
shared before the crisis lesson number
seven is that individuals must be held
accountable for their actions we've had
a number of banking crisis in our
country and they keep coming back every
10 years or so and and a lot of the time
what happens is the Bank chief
executives and management basically give
loans carelessly to themselves or to
their friends the loans are not paid
back the banks fail and the SE takes
over the bands and you know you wake up
one day on you told that the bank has
failed now I believe I say that bands
never fail they killed
you know I mean it's like seeing a man
whose throat has been slit and say the
man died he didn't die he was
slaughtered and there was a murderer
somewhere someone is responsible for
bank failure somebody gave those loans
somebody borrowed that money and did not
pay and in in many countries these
borrowers end up not paying the banks
fail they move on to borrow from other
banks they become senators they become
ministers they become governors okay and
the only losses the real losers are the
depositors usually very poor people who
have kept their life savings hundreds of
thousands of them I mean people have
died in countries from failed banks all
their savings have gone children thrown
out of school because Kofi's have gone
people can't pay medical bills because
their accounts we're locked up in banks
and they woke up one day and those banks
failed in code now I think what has
changed is that people know that first
of all bank failure is not inevitable
you can save banks but you don't just
save banks II hope people responsible in
2009 when we stepped into those banks
one of the first things we recognized
was that there were a number of vested
interest very rich Nigerians the I don't
know how many of you were following
Nigerian 2009 one of the first things I
did was to publish the names of all
those who owed banks to 50 millionaire
right above the companies the directors
the shareholders it's the list of who's
who in Nigeria because those were the
very people that were going to fight the
reforms so let everybody understand that
these rich people
okay had built their wealth on
depositors funds that they had not paid
back okay and and then we went after
them stopped them from traveling out of
the country and forced them to go and
sit down and negotiate
restructures now when they didn't and am
kentuc over a few weeks ago a few I
think two months ago we not published
the names of all those who would um con
beyond a certain amount and stopped a
Nigerian banks from lending to them
they've got very big businessmen in
Nigeria who cannot borrow again from a
Nigerian bank until they pay off the bad
loans that they've had so people have to
be held responsible the CEOs we try no
one has taken a jail sentence one was
about to be convicted two weeks before
the judge passed the sentence
coincidentally I'm not accusing anybody
of the origin the judge was promoted
under our laws having been promoted he
could not pronounce judgments so we have
to go back three years now it was a
sheer coincidence I guarantee you and
but that's the kind of thing that you
deal with the date was November 16th for
final hearing promotion November 2nd
three years of trial gone we had already
gotten a conviction in the UK by the way
in a civil case against the MD and the
particulars were the same and the
criminal charge in Nigeria so that was
14 years in jail he was looking at but
these are the kinds of issues you deal
with when you went when you're in this
situation the those who have a lot of
financial capital than by political
capital and and they get protection from
areas where you least expect so you've
got to deal again with those issues
difficult decisions like criminal
prosecutions like limiting channels for
CEOs some of the CEOs whose banks were
not under funded very difficult to take
but the way decisions are to be taken I
think not everybody accepts but beyond
that even for those who haven't served
10 years the central bank today only
approves CEO appointments for three
years so after three years the CEO has
to come has to apply again and then
we'll look at bank examination reports
look at what it just let
this will look at your compliance with
governance issues and decide to either
withhold or extend our consent and the
same thing with board members they have
12 years max but we approve for two
years so every two years nine execs have
to come back for renewal now what do we
look at for non execs do you borrow a
lot from the bank do you do contracts do
you do consultancy for the bank it's not
illegal but too much of that basically
will be grounds for thinking you could
be compromised I would simply say we
don't approve you know I mean it's not a
criminal nobody is accusing you of
anything we simply not even our constant
because it goes in to fit and proper so
gradually we're getting people to
understand the meaning of Independence
the meaning of strong governance and how
critical it is IFRS adoption is
mandatory I don't know how this is going
to help raise my remember we proceeding
with it
and we're looking at all the issues
about you know what are my personal
lessons I have hinted at the challenges
over and reform usually every time you
you choose to reform a system you've got
to ask yourself who is benefiting from
the current scheme of things so if you
if you want to deal if you want to save
a bank I mean for many of our businesses
and for many of our bankers letting the
bank fail is the easiest option because
the records are gone the CEOs coming
this year would have just gone if if
Oceania Bank had failed the sea of
Oceana could have gone away with 200
pieces of real estate in Dubai property
in south of coming she had set up a
flying club in Johannesburg membership
minimum requirement
you own a private jet so when we got
into the bank there bought two private
jets
and paid deposits for two more and this
is all would depositors money okay so
nobody knew what was happening in the
banks until we started publishing the
information so but but of course these
are people who then because of the
nature of their wealth have very strong
political connections they've
contributed political party campaigns
they have friends they have in-laws they
have relationships in the and therefore
at every point in time you get in a
stumbling block so you need to
understand who are those who benefit in
the their friends who had borrowed money
and when we started remember this joke
when I was going in for when we license
an Islamic bank and people had
comparable non-interest banking and
somebody said hey why you guys
complaining we've been having non
interest non principal banking for a
long time you know people you know so
this is at least they pay back the
principal you know people were not
paying back interest and opening back
principal and banks were collapsing so
and those beneficiaries of the system
you know so that was one at the second
is the international connections at the
beginning of the reforms when when there
was so much noise domestically I knew
there was going to be a lot of pressure
on the government to intervene and
present order and it was very helpful at
that time to have the Americans and the
British and the French basically just
mention to the government there you know
what your central bank is doing is the
right thing because African governments
do listen and and you've got to use
you've got to just use the politics as
well
I get the IMF get the World Bank to say
to them please give this guy a chance we
got the EIB to come in to extend loans
to Nigerian banks and to announce that
they rejoined this because they
supported the reforms we got the IFC to
basically make public of its 19 Aegean
banks and also say this was support for
the reforms so
the government itself was torn between
its domestic comprador allies who who
basically have always lived in one on
one form of rent or another whether it's
all subsidy or loans that they don't pay
from banks that's how people make mirin
a geometer by the private sector
apart from non goatee and the
multinationals the private sector people
who have money who don't work in
government now they probably don't
employ anyone they have no production
you know they have a briefcase and
office somebody who does protocol for
them and billions of narrative made of
billions of dollars from subsidy from
tax breaks from loans they've taken and
not paid back and so one one form of
rent or another so we'll be working with
the private sector
I see where is your factory how many
people do you employ but they progress
the economy has organized private sector
organized you know and and so you've got
to understand that now so you've got to
what the politics as well and lesson
three pick and choose your battles and
also the team there are many battles
that I walked away from when we remove
the bank management's we had the option
for moving the entire boards I didn't
want to be fighting management and
shareholders at the same time so we'd
have the non-executive board now in some
banks it was useful it they helped us in
the mergers in others became stumbling
blocks and we had to nationalize those
banks ultimately through Hong Kong
because they were just difficult they
were the ones where the problem not the
management also one example of picking
the team is lawyers at the in 2009 and I
I say this we we had very strong
reservations about the Attorney General
administer of justice
we didn't think we could rely on him to
prosecute so I basically went to the
President and said I don't trust your
Minister of Justice and I said so so
what do you want and I said I want to
appoint the lawyers they'll prosecute
the bankers the central bank will pay I
want him to give the Fiat the present
basically ordered him to give the feds
if we did not have the lawyers
persecuting the bankers will never have
convicted any of them you know because
in the course of the I have removed the
bank MDS where one of them had disappear
from laws we had credible information
that she had meetings with the Minister
of Justice okay and and therefore we
could not trust that system - so you've
got to pick your battles and you also
have to have a team that will fight
those battles and be in control of that
team a number of outcomes I think we'll
have that in the presentation I'm a
physician and F's app basically endorsed
all actions taken we have macroeconomic
stability GDP growth remains robust
inflation is at 9% January which is the
first time at its lowest in four years
ethic not 18 months its reserves that
are the highest levels and 18 months and
we've had innovations in power support
at 698 megawatts per generation saved
interest the SME loans created about
fourteen thousand new jobs increased
capacity lies ation and so on and we
have in complementary reforms I wondered
if you could touch upon the role of the
sovereign wealth fund it also came as a
result
all the ongoings in fiscal discipline
well this appear finance and Isis for a
number of years since I think going back
to 2005 where there has been an ongoing
discussion now the major problem with
swf is a constitutional problem the way
Nigeria structured government revenues
in the Federation account have to be
shared to three tiers of the Federation
federal state and local so technically
the Nigerian federal government cannot
save on behalf of state and local
governments without their consent and
the sovereign wealth fund would have
meant the federal government saving on
behalf for similar states and local
governments to save and and that has
been the major major stumbling block
because the governor's just want to have
them and in spended at the federal level
obviously we know the implications of
not having savings when all prices are
high you know we all know that the
economy benefited during the crisis from
the reserves I've been built up in the
time of of us enjoy the second term of
Obasanjo he had left about 50 billion in
reserves actually up to Erebus time to
be built to 62 and then all prices
crashed and we use those savings but the
state governors want to spend their
money and there's this whole debate over
how much okay so I think they've got a
billion dollars we should have had much
more in the sovereign wealth fund but
it's one billion dollars that has been
negotiated
now the swf is structured to have three
components one is the normal
Stabilization Fund to be used in the
event of a crash in oil prices there's
an intergenerational fund to be kept for
next generations and the third which is
strange it's an infrastructure fund to
be invested not in infrastructure abroad
but in infrastructure within Nigeria and
but that has not yet taken off it's a
billion dollars
it's a very good concept in my mind it's
it stands on shaky legal foundations
given the Constitution unless we can get
that law somehow entrenched in the
Constitution it can be challenged which
is where the government's always always
looking for a political solution thank
you thank you a tremendous admiration
research research especially taking this
and my question is more for the
perspective of investors and
entrepreneurs
while these a tremendous reforms how do
you ensure that they don't rely on the
brilliance of you know a couple of
individuals are there steps you can take
to help institutionalize them and make
sure that they're long-lasting beyond
different ten years and in a sense they
are the institutions are there I mean if
you look at apart from the uncon act for
example we're going to have to call on
any new law to do what we did so so the
central bank is there the Central Bank
Act is there both ways they're the
powers are there so in terms of
institutions you have them I think it's
it's extremely important that in
selecting public offices people select
the right people for the job and and I
suppose the the the question is when the
next governor has been selected is it
going to be selected based on his
ability to continue with these reforms
or based on loyalty to a political
administration and that that is beyond
anybody's it's really the president's
decision all we can do is his advice
ultimately no matter how strong people
talk about institutions I think I've
heard this then I think it started with
Obama and then it was very good for
African leaders Obama said Africa
doesn't need strong men it needs it
needs strong institutions and and
therefore every week African leader
quotes Obama you know as I said but but
the truth is no matter no matter how
strong the institutions are they can be
weakened by weak men you know a central
bank is independent on paper if the
governor is not independent the bank is
not independent so it's it's a
combination of keeping the law and the
autonomy of the and the integrity of
institutions but also am getting people
that match the institution's okay at the
right time I mean I may well be a
governor that's suited to a crisis
environment and after the crisis my
temperament may not be the temper
meant of you know the normal central
bank on it gets very boring I'll get
bored I'm getting bored actually right
now because because there are no fights
there no more battles inflation is done
exchange rated stable results are going
up and I'm actually getting bored you
know so maybe it's time for me to go but
you will whatever it is you will need
someone who will continue to keep an eye
on those the good thing is we've worked
with the bankers committee so in a lot
of what you've done with the banks
they've got in the bank CEOs to buy into
it and and I keep telling the bankers it
would be a major disappointment if after
I leave
they chair run and abandon these this
progress we've made on on governance on
risk management and so on
the lady the point that you mentioned
about choosing battle so happens to be
working in Nigeria in the banking sector
when you came in when you started the
reform and I and one of the things I
notice in the basis that they are run by
some of the most powerful people as
we've said already in Nigeria and I
wanted to ask at that time sort of what
gave you this confidence that the reform
would actually succeed because you're
really saying that there were strong
ties with you know the politics and it
could have happened that I mean you end
up
your victim of the system if all that
powerful stakeholders in Iran do and I
mean surprisingly it worked
but I just wanted to know when that
visionary came from that sense of it was
I I knew very well in taking the steps I
took that could well be the
shortest-lived central bank governor in
Nigeria I could easily have have been
sacrificed I think in a sense okay maybe
when I write my memoirs smoothies but
I'll tell you about a meeting I held
with the president when there is when
the reports first came out because well
first first of all it was important to
have the support of the central bank and
I remember going through that report
with the entire management of central
bank just me and the four deputy
governors and then the MD of ntic and
its executive directors and agreeing
that given the enormity of this we had
to act on eight banks but we also knew
that if we moved on eight bands there's
a simple collapse so it was a risk I
remember after the meeting now took the
decision and I went around everybody one
after the other to get their consent
I I said I want everybody to go and
sleep on this and come back tomorrow so
I gave him 24 hours you know and we came
back and I went again one after the
other to ask if after sleeping over this
you still believed in this and they said
yes and I said are you willing each of
you to commit to me that if I go to the
president and he says no we will all
resign and and I got everyone to say yes
they would resign so I went with the
event to the president in knowing that
if he said no he was going to have a
resignation of the governor and deputy
governors of the central bank on his
head and and I knew he could not handle
that politically okay so it was
something I was good I was ready to use
if he said no okay and now I
I went to the present given the scenario
said this this is the situation and and
you basically have two options one
option is to just do what the government
has always done just say these banks
have failed okay and let these guys walk
away the bank CEOs the AEDs the
borrowers and then have depositors lose
so many hundred billions of deposits the
second option is I wanted the authority
to put in four hundred billion naira
into these banks but to go after the
management and the boroughs and this is
our recommendation and the president
said he agreed now I then said to him
these are your friends they funded your
party you're going to get calls from
generals from traditional rulers from
party leaders are you sure because I
don't want to start and have you call me
a vitami to stop and then I don't stop
and we artem and he gave me his word
that he would not interfere so I had the
president's full backing and once I
secured that you know that was fine but
or something else that present area did
which I remember I was about to leave
and he said governor come back so don't
you need I go to do this alone would you
need in government so while I need the
police before for for protection of my
people
I need the SSS to make sure these guys
don't leave the country I need the FCC
to prosecute them you know he just said
well sit down and and and he called the
Inspector General of Police the chairman
of the FCC and the DG SSS and they all
came into that office one after the
other while I was there and he said you
know this man this is he has an
assignment I want you to do everything
he tells you to do so effectively
I had these three institutions working
with the central bank and he fell sick
shortly after that I went to Saudi
Arabia and knowing you know these are
all police officers so they they work on
the last or they given you know so I had
this fortunate situation where the
present was sick the new president
vice-president didn't have the executive
powers so he was in Abuja but he could
not overturn the order given to the
president's prison was alive
so I effectively had the authority to do
everything we did before before that
transition was cook was concluded you
know but was a risk and you know my view
was if we didn't do it anyway the system
would collapse it was just a matter of
time so it was actually better if it was
going to collapse it collapse
immediately you know otherwise would
save itself and actually I mean
listening to all the things that you've
said at my bravery and I hope more
African countries who have brave men
like you come and change institutions
but my question is more on the fact that
when we have porous institutions and
porous systems people who benefit from
those tend to viciously protect them and
hope to perpetuate them your your
changes that you made we ever faced with
any situations where your life was in
danger and when you had personal traits
on you and how did you deal with those
and what's your source of conviction I
did not consider any threats to be
credible II you know the first thing
you've got to when you when you're in a
society like mine you've got people who
live on right many people many people
who live on rent okay
they basically are not smart people okay
they don't know how to make money using
brains that's why they can only steal
okay
now they've got two tools only and if
you remember that you'll find they try
to bribe you or they try to frighten you
so if you're not afraid of them and if
you don't want their money you can deal
with them they've got no other tool
nothing and if you just remember that
all the time you can succeed in reform
they will do everything to compromise
you if you say no then they'll try to
frighten your you threats you know I
mean I heard things like well you know
this guy will be out of his job in two
weeks you know or are you going to be
sad then every time I'm threatened with
the sack I've offered my resignation so
you know you don't need to sack me just
tell me to go I can give it to you you
know and they can't they don't even have
the courage to accept your resignation
okay it's all they can't do anything I
said it at I mean I suppose yes when I
leave office they'll try to hound you
they put you put you in Jack's I mean
we've seen it with a brewery and
everybody and nobody it happens okay
they could get into political power they
could try to hound you out of the
country but that's that is to be
expected you don't expect to offend
people like that and not get a reaction
okay but what I think what we have done
is we have damaged them in a manner that
they've not been damaged before I mean
it takes a lot of guts for anyone who
has stolen money I'm about 200 pieces of
real estate to claim to be a victim
I mean even even in Nigeria because I
mean by by by publishing by publishing
that that list you know with addresses
you know and going to court and having
her sign to forfeit those assets and
therefore admit that she actually owns
them you know it would take a lot of
courage you know for her to come after
anybody anytime or for anybody on her
behalf come on and and basically it's I
think it's that damage that hurts more
than anything else you know it's like
with the National Assembly the whole
issue of 25%
of overheads yes they're angry but what
can they do what can you do when you've
confronted with the facts that the
National Assembly takes 25 percent of
the overheads of the federal government
I mean the facts are there you know so
people are not happy you know and
they're angry and they wish they could
do something but they're only able to do
that when they stand on some moral moral
ground you know and I think the key is
look what I say was that these guys are
going to come after me I told them I'm
at the beginning it was very clear okay
they've got to break their legs just
make sure you break their legs so that
they can crawl I mean I know they can
well with Pistorius we've seen that they
can still do some damage but but until
they get those limbs okay they're going
to remain on the ground can I just take
the let me just take those that the
hands that are up together yes please
yeah so I'm gonna have two questions
Faceman the first one is related to what
the gentleman has said regarding the
business friendly environment that that
Nigerian axe basically we know that the
interest rate has reached alone for
loans as reached a peak of 27% in April
and the average now is around 20 I'm
assuming so how how can I mean how can
we have how can we expect investors to
come in and do business and open their
new businesses in Nigeria which saturate
the second question is as we all know
and as you made it clear corruption is a
major problem in Nigeria and you're good
at fighting it apparently and you're
getting bored do you have any political
aspirations or political plan to fight
corruption on a political level
all right
can I take bit lassen and then take a
breath together so I wanted to know
earlier is sit in the side conversation
that basically would take integrating
the economies of West Africa first so
having a lot of cross production and
consumption for central banks to be
consolidated on Michael West African
level what can you do or work on the
central bank do at your level to
stimulate production and consumption
across the cross borders okay well on
the first question on interest rates
unfortunately interest rates are a
residual as you know my job is to
provide stability and if you go back in
particular to 2010 2011 when we had
elections we had a very high level of
government spending of an uncontrolled
nature I mean the central bank kept
complaining now unfortunately if you if
you're an economy like ours and you have
a lot of government spending what
happens is you get pressure on the
exchange rate pressure on reserves and
if you're an import dependent economy as
exchange rates we can you have inflation
so in terms of my core mandate a central
bank a fiscal exuberance makes my job
difficult now the only way I can have
stable exchange rates a stable inflation
rate and protect reserves itself high
interest rates and this is what I keep
explained to the government I mean the
government wants to spend money I don't
have low interest rates you know so I
mean again my members have a number of
interesting conversations with my bosses
and we were sitting with the president
and he was saying well you know interest
rates are too high and I said well your
excellency where would you like the
naira to be 180-200 with 250 so because
you can't have a stable naira you know
and and low interest rates at this time
you just tell me you wanted evaluation
by 25 30 % LD value the naira and give
you low rates of interest you know
because people
go to him and comparable interest rates
they don't tell him what are the
implications of lowering interest rates
you know and for me that you see this is
a country remember where we had a Sikh
president then a dead president then a
difficult transition electoral violence
we came out of the Niger Delta we now
have Boko Haram with bombs exploding if
we have instability in exchange rates
and reserves and inflation the economy
is gone the only thing that's keeping
that economy alive is the stability that
we've been able to give and it's
something that we cannot take for
granted now well interest rates come
down I think they will unfortunately and
this is very sad 2014's elections but
the kind of work in Gaza has done since
she came in or you know has helped us
okay basically Iranian inflation so yes
we haven't in we've ever reduced rates
but we all would also increase them in
eight MPC meetings and in January
inflation was nine percent actually
single-digit still at least the first
half of the year before it starts coming
up again due to cyclical factors now
that gives us room for for easing would
we ease I don't know I mean I my
personal view is we shouldn't but I'm
only one vote on MPC I don't see any
reason why we should ease ahead of an
election year because with ease and by
January February when government start
spending money we have to start rolling
back the progress we've made so if you
get inflation to eight seven percent and
this payment goes to nine ten we're fine
but if you sat easing and get to ten I
think instead looking at twelve thirteen
percent inflation you don't have a
problem so that's it not on corruption
you see corruption is a problem but I
have a have a certain theory that
corruption is not the biggest problem in
Nigeria or in Africa
it's the nature of intervention that
corruption invites and I'll explain if
you look at if you catch emerging
markets if you get Indonesia and
Malaysia and China these economies are
growing and there's a lot of corruption
in those economies so the idea that
corruption in itself gets in the way of
growth it's something that I don't agree
with okay my example always is if you if
you come to Nigeria and build a 2000
megawatt plant of electricity and you
give some public offices 10% of it it's
corruption it as to the cost of services
but the intervention of bringing in 2000
megawatts of electricity creating
factories creating jobs creating incomes
the benefit to the economy far outweighs
the costs of the five ten percent that
you've put in corruption now if you
bribe a government official so as to pay
you subsidy for petroleum products that
you do not bring in or if you bribe a
government official so that they can
turn their head around while you're
stealing crude oil and selling that's a
different ballgame
if you bribe a government official so
they give you a contract that you do not
perform on you don't build the road you
don't build the bridge you don't build
the port that's a different matter so
the more we focus on how much money
public servants are making without
looking at the great damage of ministers
being in office for four years and
delivering nothing the less we miss the
point if your Minister of Works for four
years and you've not built a road and
simply because you belong to the right
political party or have loyalty to the
president after four years you get
reappointed a minister we kill the
country few minutes of power for four
years
I've not generated electricity if your
means of agriculture and you've not
improved our cultural productivity at
the end of the day we've got
start asking what are people in office
opposed if you're governor of central
bank what is the rate of inflation
what is exchange rate what is ramming
people tell me I'm not loyal to the
government and I say I do how do I prove
my loyalty to the president get into bed
with him I mean what does that mean
I manage inflation you if it's a banking
system your fixed exchange rate what
else do you want
now people need to start asking what is
the minister supposed to emergency done
so I think we should fight corruption
but far more important which you fight
mediocrity and incompetence and and that
is the biggest the biggest problem on on
integration well first of all I'm just
Oh political politics er no I have no no
desire and I keep repeating that because
it gets me to a lot of trouble because
people think I I do applications I have
no desire to get into partisan politics
Italy and any desire and we have had any
thoughts I may have had I think have
ever preached it after three years in
Abuja I don't think I don't think I can
survive in that environment but you see
on integration it's really about the
right economic policies and about Africa
thinking look look at Europe okay you've
got the political bodies but when when
when a German investor is thinking of
and he doesn't think of himself as being
constrained by the border of Germany he
thinks of Europe okay he sees Europe as
a market and I think it's about our
beginning to think beyond political
borders I give the example of Bashar
initiators of the north of Nigeria 20
million people only 15% of the land is
arable now for me that is a great
opportunity for energy agriculture to
feed a neighboring country and so rather
than have me share wait for France and
other nations to come for aid okay now
should is it one way traffic know you've
got telecoms fibre transatlantic coming
from Algeria all the way to New Jersey
near me
now if you want fiber in Colonel or may
degree in northern Nigeria it's much
much faster and cheaper to get you from
nature than to transport to build 1,200
miles of cable from legals okay so
integration okay actually becomes easy
when you can keep making the economic
arguments arguments for it you've got
oil in the Niger Delta yes but you've
got all been produced in Chad in
Cameroon in nature in the Chad basin
which means is all in the Chad basin in
Nigeria produce all there okay a build
refineries there so and if you build a
refinery in southern Nigeria you could
basically build pipelines to Cameroon
build pipelines to other parts of Africa
you know so basically it's about
specialization Nigeria should produce
for me all the petroleum based
industries in West Africa and which be
able to sell to those countries and be
able to import as well from those
countries and and treat part of nyjah's
as landlords so it's about African
leaders thinking in terms of
specialization in terms of building
infrastructure in terms of human capital
final point if you take Africa as one
market okay you'll find that most of the
goods consumed in Africa are produced in
Asia okay but 90 percent of those goods
can be produced in Africa using African
raw material and labor why does any
African country need to import textiles
and fabric from China with all the
cotton in Africa why'd you need import
tomato paste
why don't you import petroleum products
why do you need import plastics
I mean basic industries Chinese labor
the costs have gone up in the last 30
years labor costs in China three four
times what they were two decades ago in
1960 70s China had an advantage of
having cheaper labor than Africa now
labor in China is far wiser than Africa
where does Africa what
China beat Africa it's the technical and
vocational skills productivity and
infrastructure
so what Africa needs to do is build
infrastructure build the technical
education and see China's competition
have always said it take away the
manufacturing from China let the Chinese
firms come and produce on African soil
ok and sell to the African market and
export from African soil and that way
you preserve for an exchange
you create a domestic market you expand
consumption demand and you expand GDP
but so long as you keep importing these
Goods you're not going to have the
structural change that you need to move
out of poverty you go to continue
presort
what happens now China takes raw
material from Africa they buy cotton
they buy and it they take them solid
minerals from Africa they buy commodity
so it's the old imperialism again ok
where Africa is exporting raw materials
and importing finished goods so the real
change we need to have is how do you
begin to produce those goods on African
soil take away the manufacturing from
China ok or from Chinese soil to African
soil
create jobs and Africa and export of
Africans or that is the direction I see
for Africa African Development without
it frankly we still have a long way to
go
you